but a proportion is a ratio that's equal
to a ratio right so together this forms
of proportion and we know how to solve
proportions we can cross multiply we can
say a times D equals B times C right
okay but let's go through some of the
properties so one thing that we can do
when we have a proportion like this is
we can take the reciprocal of both sides
so if I flip this over and say B over a
what does that equal well it would be D
over C now if you want to confirm that
you can cross multiply C a times D right
equals B times C right now another
property of proportions is you can
interchange these quantities on the
diagonal so if I switch the a and the D
we've got D over B equals C over a now
again you can cross multiply you can see
a times D right equals B times C and
then also you can interchange them on
this diagonal same thing you've got a
divided by C equals B divided by D right
again you can check ad equals BC now the
one that tricks students the most is
this one here and it's that a plus B
over B equals C plus D over D now
students are thinking you know what
what's going on here right but what you
can look at is you can say well there's
my a over B and my C over D right that's
what we started with
but look what we've added on we've added
on B over B to the left side of the
equation and D over D to the right side
of the equation so if we split this up a
over B plus B over B equals C over D
plus D over D but B over B is really
just like 1 right same thing with D over
D that's really just like 1 so all we
did was add 1 to both sides of the
equation so it's still you know
equivalent it's still balanced it's
still equal we just added 1 to both
sides right so a typical example might
look something like this say you have
let's say if x over 2 equals 7 over 5
then what does x plus 2 over 2 equal
right well that would equal 12 over 5 so
what it looks like just at first glance
is that you're adding the de nom
to the numerator as long as you do it to
both sides I'm adding 2 to the numerator
here 5 to the numerator there but it's
really like doing it's really like
adding 2 over 2 and then here I added 5
over 5 2 or 2 is 1 5 over 5 is 1 you're
just adding 1 to both sides of the
equation so I hope this helped you
understand how to work with the
properties of proportions better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon